hello learners
every online business is in the race to
grab the first position in the search
results and hold on to it as far as
possible
to rank higher there are several factors
that we need to consider like
having unique content for audiences
having seo optimized website
having large number of backlinks
and a good social media presence
in this video
we will focus on what backlinks are
what make backlinks an important ranking
factor
moving ahead we will understand do
follow and no follow backlinks
pay your keen attention when we start
with white hat and black hat links
moving forward we will understand how to
build backlinks for your website and
finally we will check backlinks building
tools and future of backlinks
before diving deep into the topic
consider subscribing to our channel and
press the bell icon to never miss any
updates from simplylearn
so let me demonstrate you how this video
will prove a game changer for your
online business
let's go to google.com
how to make
pizza
so here you can see there are number of
results
uh these type of results are called with
snippets and below you'll get the list
of
top 10 search results
on the first page of the
serps
so here we are we are going to find
the backlinks for the first and the last
result
so let's copy the link
open it in the new tab
and
copy the link and now we will go to rf's
backlink checker
just to add to your information rfs
backlink checker is a free backing
checker tool
now here we will be adding the url
and check backlinks
so here you can see there are 288
backlinks with the 22 percent of do
follow links we are going to learn the
do follow and no followings in the
coming part of the video so stay tuned
now let's check the backlinks for the
last search result
which is
here
we'll open the link and
copy the link here
go to
rf's checker
and add the url and again the same
procedure
so okay so here we can find that number
of backlinks are more as compared to
previous one here there are 346
backlinks with six percent of do follow
links so now there is a question that
though there are there is
uh more backlinks in the
last resort why it's not why it's
ranking to the last position so here is
the answer that
having more number of backlink is
definitely a ranking factor
but the backlink should be do follow
links
if you have more number of do follow
links then it is more likely to result
high on the search results as compared
to
less number of do followings
that's why
the last
that's why here you can see that
this link is at the last of the search
result whereas this one inside the first
okay so
now again
let's search for best
jogging
shoes
okay we are not taking the ads we will
check for the organic results which are
here
so let's click on the first result
copy the link
and go to
rf's backlink checker
add your url
and check for backlinks
meanwhile we'll go and check for the
last result
okay this this one is the last
copy the link
go to
rf's backlink checker
and enter the url
check backlinks
okay
so here you can see a huge difference
the first first result is having 3395
with 94 percent of do follow links
whereas the last result is having only
183 backlinks with only two percent of
do follow links definitely to rank
higher there are several factors and
backlinks are one of them
let's understand what backlinks are
when a web page receives a hyperlink
from another website
it is known as a backlink a backlink is
also known as inbound links
let's understand this more clearly
this is an article on best pizza company
it has a list of pizzas mentioned
here you can see a link attached to each
company
when you click on the link it opens the
website or the company's home page
here the company's home page gets one
backlink from the website on which
article is present
now as we are familiar with what
backlinks are let's understand what make
backlinks an important ranking factor
when a web page receives more and more
backlinks
this helps search engine understand that
your web pages content is valuable
which makes other websites to link to
you
thereby gaining their trust
as search engines
loves the unique and valuable content
they consider it to rank high in the
search results
this makes backlinks an important factor
and a symbol of trust as well
however it is not necessary that if you
get lots of backlinks that means you
will rank high for sure
you will rank high only when you get
high quality backlinks
backlinks are said to be high quality
when linked juice or authority from one
website is passed to another
and to understand this
there is a need for proper understanding
of no follow and do follow links
a website can link to your page either
by do follow or by no follow links
do follow links are beneficial in terms
of seo when a website links back to your
site by do follow link it passes the
authority or the link juice
of their website to yours
this helps to improve the authority of
your website thereby positively
affecting the ranking
coming to nofollow links
these links do not pass authority or
link juice to your website therefore
these are not beneficial in terms of seo
however even though it directly does not
affect the ranking of your website still
no follow links are good for driving
user traffic
from one website to another
now that we have gained knowledge about
do follow and nofollow links i would
like to bring your attention to some of
the practices followed by optimizers to
get the backlinks
white hat and blackhead techniques to
get backlinks optimizers mostly follow
white hat or black hat techniques
the white hat technique helps to gain
backlinks under search engine guidelines
talking about blackhead techniques
these involves spammy methods of gaining
backlinks
and one can get penalized by search
engines
if search engines detect the black hat
methods so on a serious note we
recommend you to follow white hat
techniques strictly
so without taking a minute let's start
understanding the methods of how to
build backlinks
here we go with our first technique
which is skyscraper technique
this technique is originally said to be
found by brian dean the founder of
backlinko
publishing a skyscraper content can help
you to bring backlink from high
authority sites for this you need to do
the basic research and find the content
that is doing well in your industry
once you find the content create a
better version of this content with
additional unique information
now
all you need is to promote your content
then you can reach out to experts with
similar interest and ask them to add the
url of your content
which will be an add-on to their
existing content
and that's it
another method of building backlinks is
publishing detail guides
detailed guides are the form of longer
content studies say that longer contents
tends to gain more backlinks
however remember that publishing longer
content will work only if the content is
unique and informative
getting to know about broken link
building
all you need to do is
find the informative pages which are
relevant to your industry on the web
that have dead links or 4.4 pages
4.4 pages have a negative impact on
search engines
if you have relevant content that could
replace this 4.4 page
do reach out to the owner of the content
and have a humble ask
to replace the dead link with your
content definitely it's difficult but
yes this technique really works
next we can get backlinks by finding
listicles
to add plus to your knowledge
listicles are a piece of writings that
has list included in them
all you need to do is find the content
which has list of relevant topics now
check if it includes your site also
if not you can ask the owner of the
content to include your site with a
brief description of how it is helpful
and relevant to the existing content
now let's talk about another technique
helpful in gaining backlinks which is
guest blogging
guest blogging is a simple and easy way
to earn backlinks
first you need to identify blogging site
with high domain authority
create a blog post relevant to your
industry
with the links of your site and add this
post to the blogging sites do not add
too many links as they will appear
spammy in the eyes of search engines
which may prove harmful to your site
next we move towards
another technique which is link gap
building
link gap analysis is the quickest way
from which one can easily discover the
link building opportunities
by carrying out link gap analysis you
can find the sites that link to your
competitors but not you
so suppose if you find a website that
links to more than one of your
competitors their chances of linking to
you increases as we have seen some of
the effective backlink building methods
now let's see some tools you will need
for building backlinks using the above
methods here we go with our first tool
helpful in battling building which is
sem rush it is helpful in competitor
analysis and finding link gaps
it has free as well as paid version
next we have rfs
link intersect feature helps to get the
reports on the sites that link to your
competitors but not you
this feature comes under the paid
version
upcoming tool is another interesting
tool which is helpful in building
backlinks which is group high
it helps you to get bloggers reach
this tool is a paid tool
next we have hunter dot io
it is an email address finder that helps
you to get email addresses of people
from a particular domain or even their
personal ids
it has free as well as paid versions
we have learned almost all the aspects
of backlink building
now let's have a quick look
at what is in the future of backlinks
backlinks are one of the most important
factors in search engine ranking as it
shows the trust of one site into another
gaining high quality backlink makes the
search engines understand that the
content on your website is valuable
thereby making it eligible for higher
rankings however due to spammy methods
backlinks are the factor that can be
easily manipulated
as we know that search engine algorithms
are continuously updated backlinks will
continue to be an important ranking
factor but the unique content and
user-centric content will be more valued
this is it with our today's session i
hope you have gained enough knowledge on
how to build backlinks if you have any
queries let us know in the comment
section below and do not miss to
subscribe simply learn and press the
bell icon to never miss an update from
simplyland thanks for watching this
video
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here